Age gaps, age gaps,
age gap. I agree.
This is a very nice comment.
She has a point. Most men don't wanna settle down before the age of 25.
She's saying that if women had men that wanted to settle down,
that we would probably consider having babies sooner.
And yes, but again,
with our culture, we demonize age gaps between men and women,
which doesn't make sense because historically speaking,
we have always dated up.
I got engaged at 20 and I don't know what I was thinking.
He was the same age as me,
in fact I was a few months older.
But like, maturity wise,
I was ready to have babies and settle down
and he wanted to do silly frat boy things.
I hundred percent should have been dating someone when I was like 23.
I should have been dating a 30 year old.
And my husband and I now have a 7 or 8 year age gap.
And yeah, it makes sense.
I met him when he was like 37,
so he for sure was not married for a reason before then.
Boys take a little bit of time.
But if you tell a 22 year old to date a 30 year old,
everyone thinks it's creepy.
Again, doesn't make sense.
That's when women are the most fertile,
that's when they're the youngest,
that's when they're the most youthful and pretty to men biologically.
Now, I'm a huge proponent of like,
thriving in your 30s I feel like I hit my.
My peak in my thirties. So I am not age shaming any girls,
but 100%
we should not be sending girls to college with the same age of boys
thinking that they're gonna be safe, protected,
loved, cherished,
or even find a husband. And unfortunately,
we tell girls that they need to spend their entire twenties
getting a career and chasing the boss
babe life instead of finding a good man.
My mother had four kids and then went back to college,
and I watched her walk when I was in high school
and then still had another 20 years to build a career.
People think I'm sexist for saying the things that I'm saying,
but I think our society is sexist,
telling us to waste our small,
fertile window on becoming corporate slave
instead of dating up and finding a good man.
Here's the key. Man,
not boy. So, yeah,
I think you're completely right with this statement.
Um, a lot of women do want good men.
It's just
I feel like our culture teaches us to look for them in wrong ways.
One of the prime examples of this is 50 shades of gray.
Every girl loved it. He was, like,
in his 30s, and she just graduated college,
probably at 21. And while she was at bars, drinking,
making bad decisions. Remember the scene where she drank too much
and he showed up to rescue her?
You told her the next Day. Hey,
you put yourself in a dangerous situation.
You shouldn't be doing that.
As much as everyone wants to get pissed about it,
every girl was walking that going,
oh my god, that is so hot,
he's daddy. But then at the same time,
we are taught by our culture that in our 20s
we don't wanna be told what to do
because we're independent women.
But that's the difference,
sir. Man,
that is a difference between dating a boy in his 20s
who wants to put you in dangerous,
precarious situation versus a man who wants to take care of you.
I wish I had found my husband when I was like 23 and he was like
thirty. I don't know what he would have been, 30.
The universe just took some time to bring us together.
But yeah,
everyone is so quick to hate on age gaps.
But then every girl watches 50 shades of gray and they're like,
I love him. Age gap!
Age gap, age gap.
Date up! Date up,
date up. If I have a girl and she wants to get married young
and she's in her 20s, I am 100% gonna tell her,
don't be dating men your same age.
Those are my thoughts. Thank you for the sweet comment.
I love it when people interact and they do it in a kind way.